hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the distinct pleasure of sitting today
with iona italia who
shortly will become editor-in-chief of
reo magazine
and is the author of our tango world
did i get that all right iona it was
perfect yes
well welcome to dark horse thank you so
much brett
so this conversation is one i have
wanted to have with you for the longest
time and you and i in fact discussed the
possibility of us having this
conversation
must be a couple of years ago now at
least maybe two or three
i i think only maybe a year and a half a
year and a half well my wife is
constantly telling me that i have an
atrocious sense of how much time has
passed
she's often nicer when she says this but
my interpretation is that i am very bad
at figuring out how much time has passed
but
in any case i'm really glad that you're
here i have been
reading your book i won't say i've read
it all but i
am fascinated by it in a way
that i was not expecting and so maybe if
you'll allow me i'll just say a few
words about where i am with respect to
something like
tango and i'll catch the audience up on
what conversation i'm hoping will have
so of course i have a little experience
with
partner dancing mostly it comes from the
fact
that partner dancing is obviously
still a very big deal across latin
america and
i did graduate work in central america
and so i encountered this and i did
enough dancing to sort of
know what it's about i wouldn't say i'm
any good at it but i'm
good enough to have had the experience
and sort of
see what the potential is there and it
has caused me to do a lot of thinking
about dance and the west and
and where we are and what the two might
have to do with each other
and i must say i've thought
many times about tango it's obviously a
very
provocative and conspicuous dance in a
way
but my sense has always been as much as
i would in principle love to be able
to tango merengue i can do
salsa is difficult for me tango is
surely so
far out of the range of possibilities
that it wasn't worth thinking about it
in personal terms
and your book changes my opinion of this
somewhat i'm not sure that i ever
will but it does compel me that there
would be a reason
to try worthy opportunity there
well those are fighting words because i
often visit portland
um so watch out all right well i would
be thrilled
to to try tango with you um i'm
especially heartened there's
one passage in your book i believe
you're quoting someone else
who says that as a beginner you can't
possibly
be bad that it takes years to become bad
and i i love this sentiment
yes that's actually um i'm not quoting
anyone that's my
um my little aphorism
um you can't be a bad dancer if you're a
beginner
it takes years to become a bad dancer
well it's wonderful i think i i thought
it was someone else because it appears
at the beginning of a chapter and it
has a couple of words below it but
anyway i'm sorry for misinterpreting
that it is indeed
wonderful i will just say sort of
generally about your book
the i it revealed to me something i
think you and i
are kindred spirits in a way
um there's a very famous
discussion with feynman where feynman
reports
that a friend of his accused him and all
scientists
of taking the beauty of nature and
insisting on dissecting it right taking
apart a flower where all of its
beauty is lost and feynman responds
to this friend that that's that he's got
it wrong
that in fact the scientist does take the
flower apartment apart to figure out why
it works or how it works but that this
gives the scientists
both kinds of pleasure the scientists
can enjoy the flower
and can enjoy the delight in discovering
what it is about and that one does not
detract from the other
and so as an evolutionary biologist
i look at nature and i cannot stop
myself from thinking
about why why is it the way it is
and it does not in any way reduce my
pleasure
in being in nature and in reading your
book i have the sense that you are
simultaneously fully invested in
the experience of tango
and that you are also fully invested in
comprehending
what it means and where it comes from
and how these things interact
and so uh anyway i like a person who
is willing to invest in both of those
channels
and it makes me all the more hopeful
that we can get
to uh the deep questions that are raised
by tango specifically and
dance more generally i think
so i have also always enjoyed i don't
have a scientific background at all
but i've always enjoyed reading popular
science
books and i
do feel there's a a real sense of awe
and delight in just
how complex and
beautiful the workings of nature are
and i think that richard dawkins book
the ancestors tale is one of the most
moving books i have ever read and it
actually
moved me to tears to read his book um
and i also um you know there are certain
science books that had
have left me in this just state of
intense pleasure for days afterwards
for example i read a book on
photosynthesis
which was written quite a while ago it's
called eating the sun
i'm afraid i don't remember who the
author was
but and i could no longer tell you how
photosynthesis works he explained it in
great
and careful meticulous uh detail one
stage after another
um and i remember you know a few little
little things about it but i don't
remember the mechanism at all and
wouldn't be able to tell you anything
about the book i just remember
it's like that thing that um
it's that thing that you don't remember
exactly what you were told but you
remember how it made you feel
and i just remember this kind of
wow sensation at finding out
just um just kind of how much is going
on beneath the surface
at this sort of micro level that we
don't have access to when we're just
looking with our eyes
in normal life 100 agree i used to refer
to this as the cosmic joke
when i was teaching i would tell my
students that there were
an infinite number of ways to tell the
cosmic joke but
you know one of them is alluded to in
the title of the book you're referring
to
right the fact is when you look at a
tree
to realize that it is literally
the process of extracting
energy from a fusion reactor millions of
miles away
in order to take components of air and
to turn them
into sugar and plant fibers
right just to discover that the air
becomes
sugar and wood through a fusion reaction
uh that isn't even local to the earth is
stunning and you know at one level
probably everybody who went
through intro bio knows that
at another level until you've realized
what an improbable story that is
you haven't understood its meaning right
it's yes
yes absolutely yeah i think that there's
there's kind of a parallel with writing
in that
um i have occasionally encountered
people who've totally misunderstood the
writing process
once for example i was dancing with a
friend of mine
and midtender attender is a set of songs
so we dance
tango for your listeners in in these
sets of three or four songs
and midtender he stopped and
he got all kind of panicked and he said
i feel really self-conscious because i'm
afraid that as we're
dancing you are describing in your head
and thinking about how you're going to
express it later and this is completely
wrong
writing at least for me and i think for
most writers
is comes from memory wordsworth called
an emotion recollected in tranquility
and it's when i'm actually dancing i'm
focused only on dancing and i'm not
verbalizing anything mentally at all
what i'm doing when i'm writing is
after having danced i'm sitting down and
reflecting on the experience and that's
when i'm
trying to translate the experience into
words
and it's a very very
rough and vague and sort of
idiosyncratic translation because
dancing and language are
two completely different schema
but i'm trying to convey how i felt at
the time and what the experience was
like
at the time but it doesn't detract from
the experience at all it's an entirely
separate
phase it's the after after phase
and it allows me to live through things
twice
in a sense so if i can
try to translate this into my own
language
the model that heather and i have been
using teaching from and deploying
is one in which most things especially
things that one
does very well where you get in the zone
and things
go really right your conscious mind your
conscious mind which is almost
synonymous
with or in our language it is synonymous
with that fraction
of your cognition that you can explain
that you can exchange with others
your conscious mind is present for these
things but
more or less as spectator right some
other part of you
is dancing or skiing or whatever it is
that you're in
in that flow state but your conscious
mind is paying attention
and it is there to pick up the slack if
there is ever an
error if something that you don't expect
causes you to be somewhere
you weren't anticipating your conscious
mind can figure out what to do
but you're almost always better off in
that state where
your conscious mind is aware but it's
not driving
does that uh line up with what you're
saying i think
yes uh yes and no i think that's a very
good analogy
um i think there is when dancing there's
a sweet spot
between um it's very pleasurable to just
be in a kind of dance trance
that is the sort of chick scent um chick
sent me high in
flow state that man whose name must
always be cut and pasted
and
that that kind of sense of just
surfing um the music of just being taken
by the wave
is very pleasurable and at the other end
of the scale
is feeling very self-conscious
trying to second-guess yourself
feeling as soon as you for example if
you are off balance when you're dancing
then you immediately go straight back to
the this self-conscious state of
how can i repair this but
for me the the most pleasurable state is
somewhere in between where you are
um you're both immersed in the
experience and you also have this
feeling of conscious competence
of just confidence in yourself because
you know you can do this and you can
feel your body moving
graciously and gracefully um
but you're not having to put in effort
to make that happen but you are you are
aware of it
um so i find i i feel that it's not
quite a trance
it's not quite a trance state that i
like the best
but this this kind of moment of
of awareness
yes so sort of hovering at the the
boundary
of consciousness i think i think these
two things that we're describing are
are alike um
but let's uh let's delve a little
further here
um so i do want to say i i very much
appreciate especially after
reading around in your book um
the specialness of tango and it really i
think
from what i've read it's fair to say it
is an
utterly unique dance tradition much
newer than i realized you describe in
your book that it is effectively um
a how did you how did you put it the
culture of buenos aires in which it
arose
uh you care to describe it um yes so
tango really developed
um i describe it as an urban folk dance
the urban
folk dance of buenos aires and
it began at the very end of the 19th
century
and the real golden age of tango was
between
around 1935 and 1955
the golden age of the tango music and
that is when the dance really developed
in sophistication
and at that time in buenos aires
um buenos aires was
a backwater through most of the 18th and
19th century because there's really
nothing there
until the spaniards came and they
brought corn and they brought
um they brought um uh sweetheart maize
and they brought
um cattle there was nothing to eat
there was all there were almost i mean
there are very few indigenous peoples in
the pampas region
and um there was just this little kind
of malaria written
seaside town and
there was almost almost nothing
happening there
and then in the 19th century there were
a number of
huge waves of immigration mostly around
half the immigrants came from
italy and the
the two next most largest groups were
spaniards and russian jews who are
fleeing the pogroms
buenos aires has one of the world's
largest jewish populations
and at the the peak of that
immigrant period more than 60 percent
of people living in buenos aires were
not argentine born
and at a similar period in new york it
was only around 14
so buenos aires was several times more
um more diverse than
than new york and unlike new york buenos
aires was never
ghettoized so um people were
living very close together people from
different nations and cultures and
languages were all living
very close together in this communal
housing which
we called conventions
uh so that's the environment in which
tango
developed and it was also
elsewhere in europe towards the end of
the 19th century and beginning of the
20th century
many of the european cities were very
heavily industrialized
and a lot of people were just shackled
to 18 hour a day factory work
and under those kinds of conditions you
can't
develop a
a nuanced and sophisticated and rich
art tradition for art you need leisure
um
and buenos aires was never heavily
industrialized and argentina still is
is very much dependent on raw material
exports
um so there were very few factories
there in buenos aires
and most people were living on
living a kind of semi-agrarian lifestyle
and selling vegetables from small
holdings outside the city
and that kind of lifestyle is it's
intense work but only at certain
times of day and seasons of the year etc
if there's bad weather you have to stay
home
and if you stay home you can take out
your guitar and start strumming around
and creating a tune and um you can get
up and do a few steps
so that's the ideal environment for
um art to develop and in a sense that is
still happening today but for
for less less fortunate reasons
um all of the economic crises and the
very high unemployment
and sort of semi-employment and kind of
casual employment in buenos aires has
left people with a lot of
enforced leisure which many people have
spent
developing tango so
um i think uh the word i would use
for this is it's extremely cosmopolitan
i don't know that that's the right word
but you make very clear
in the book in fact i think you say that
dancers of tango may judge each other
based on their degree of skill but they
would not judge each other based on
their politics their ethnicity uh
their country of origin
and go ahead yeah i think that's true
so the thing with tango is
um you're not primarily talking to each
other so you're not liable to get into
an
argument um nor are you kind of
getting together in some kind of group
so there isn't a sense of the in-group
versus the
group what people are after is
an experience of a blissful physical
experience on the dance floor
and therefore most people's absolute
primary concern is
will this person give me a joyful
experience on the dance floor
well you say this uh i mean we're in
very different situation because
you're in london and i'm in the us
and the u.s is currently breaking down
over political divisions that would
cause i believe most people to regard
sharing a uh a dance-like tango with
somebody from the other team
to be essentially immoral
now i find this preposterous but the
idea that just because
you're not speaking words that these
things are not
taken as a barrier requires a certain
understanding and it's an understanding
that i think americans were
working towards and we are now losing
touch with what we
knew quite recently and so this really
is
in in reading this passage or these
several passages
about this topic in in your book
i was struck by the idea that we have
a relatively new dance tradition
and that it functions uh
to facilitate the
uh harmoniousness within a melting pot
and you describe a melting pot
you know buenos aires being much more
diverse
than new york was at a corresponding
period
and so i find something very compelling
about this idea
and it actually extends the
the thing that initially had me wanting
to talk to you
about partner dancing and so if i can
just lay that out briefly
my sense is that partner dancing is
very important at least it has been very
important in some
cultures and that the loss of a
tradition of partner dancing
that is to say a tradition in which
everybody
would have participated in it has caused
at least part of the derangement that we
see
in the west in effect that
especially when it comes to sex there
are certain things that are
well worked out on a dance floor that
are not so well worked
out in a culture where you're expecting
to take somebody to bed
instead of going dancing and
in any case what you write about tango
and about the
cosmopolitan environment in which it's
taking place and the suspension
of suspicion around politics and
ethnicity and
other such matters uh all
fits quite well and what i really hope
we can
unpack is whether or not
this is and by this i mean a
dance tradition that involves couples
is this an important tool in the human
tool kit
that when removed causes some kind of
predictable and important dysfunction
i think that
there are very very bitter political
divides in argentina
and i mean argentina has an extremely
bloody and horrifying recent history
argentina has only been a stable
democracy since 1983.
and um
i i i mean the kinds of
arguments that people have on facebook
among my argentine friends
just make twitter look like a
endless love bombing by comparison
but nevertheless what happens on the
dancefloor is that the
all the incentives are aligned in such a
way as to
make it make it favorable for you to
to avoid those kinds of conflicts
and or to ignore those kinds of
conflicts
um because the reward is
if you are dancing with someone with
whom you dance well
who dances well with whom you dance well
the
reward in emotionally and hormonally and
everything else is so great that
um it not just it certainly nudges you
in the direction of disregarding those
things
people are exceptionally many people are
exceptionally choosy about who they
dance with
but almost always they are choosing on
the basis of
the pleasure that they think they're
going to get or not get
with that person in that moment but
implied in that
is that the pleasure will be generated
largely by boy
i don't even know how to describe it but
the
skill and compatibility of the person
it'll it will be resident to the dance
space rather than a
uh visceral response to the individual
on the other side yes i think so
although it's it's hard to separate
those things so in tango
one of the um most striking
characteristics of tango and the way in
which it most differs from
many other partner dance forms is the
embrace
in tango and so in most
partner dances you hold each other in
some kind of hold so your your bodies
are not that closely touching
um or in many dances you just hold hands
a lot of the time
in say swing and lindy hop and very
frequently in salsa um
and in tango we hold people
in as close as we can get it while still
being able to move
we hold people in exactly the same way
as you would hold somebody in a
tender and loving situation and
although in tango that is just a gesture
you don't actually
love the person nevertheless i
think that there are um just concomitant
effects and um hormonal responses my
friend janice wang has done some
observational studies on people's
hormone levels while dancing
and their oxytocin levels go through the
roof
when they're dancing tango testosterone
also shoots up
and serotonin and stress hormones go
down
there is just a kind of um
i mean if you hold somebody in a ver in
this very tender manner
then it is very difficult to completely
divorce that
from the sense memory of of
how we usually express affection and it
is more i
i feel that it's um
um an especially intimate way of holding
them so even if
in salsa merengue and some of those
other dance bachata
um you can have more groin
groin to groin contact and in tango it's
very unusual to have below the waist
well you have contacted foot and leg
level but it's very
rare to have groin level contact
um but nevertheless if you are
beginning a romance with somebody you
don't go and stick your groin next to
their crime
i don't advise that you know you
you how very old-fashioned of you
[Laughter]
and you bring your face close to their
face and you hold their hand and that is
exactly what we also do
in when we're dancing so let's unpack
that a little bit
so um just speaking at the level of the
physics
right if you're holding somebody's upper
body very close
then in order not to topple over you
actually have to free the lower body
to move right so that you can dance
effectively and
you know i'm i don't know if you will
have noticed this but
uh i find if i hold a cup of coffee as i
walk up the stairs
i have no problem not sloshing it but if
i pin something
like a magazine under my elbow it
becomes impossible not
to slosh the coffee out because i've
constrained one of the axes on which you
would correct and so
i think what you're suggesting is that
dances probably break down into these
two categories which part of you is
going to be
free right yes yes that's a good way of
putting it
it's in the embrace is one of the things
that
that gives tango a quite steep learning
curve at the beginning
of the dance i mean tango is a folk
dance it's not a
professional dance you don't have to be
a dancer to dance tango
it doesn't require any special
flexibility or
cardiovascular fitness a lot of the
older dancers
are obese chain smoking alcoholics
so it's it's not like dancing ballet or
something but i think it is the most
difficult of the
partner dances to begin learning and
that is because it is intrinsically
difficult to move with somebody right
here in your face
and in order to in order for the dance
to work
you have to coordinate your movement
quite closely
and it means that you are also have less
independence especially as the follower
but both party
partners have less independence
if i'm dancing with say lindy hop with
somebody
and he is not a very good dancer i might
be
a bit bored or frustrated he might be
off the music maybe he'll be yanking my
arm a little bit
but i can still do my part of the dance
whereas if i'm dancing with someone in
tango who's a very bad dancer
there are ways of compensating getting
around this a bit
which we have to use as we're learning
but if he's
a bad enough dancer i literally can't
move um
you know my my ability to move
fluidly and and on balance and all of
those things is absolutely dependent
on his moving in a certain way and
communicating that to me
okay so this is very important i think
in order to have the discussion at least
the one that i'm hoping to get to
we're gonna have to separate two
categories and you actually do
a really good job of exploring many
aspects of this in your book but
there are things about partner dancing
that
are obviously connected to sex and then
there are other things that distinguish
the two things
right and my hypothesis
would be that that boundary is an
important one
but what you're describing i would say
is a place in which dancing and sex have
a very close
analogy right i think it's probably
if you have sex with somebody and
you think it was great and they think it
was terrible
something's off right there you go it
was terrible
the person who thinks it was terrible is
correct is correct
inherently so um and
i would say further that there's
something about
um
i don't even know how to say this
exactly but sex isn't the kind of thing
that you have it and you achieve some
level of proficiency and you
know retire on your laurels with a
personal best it's like a
even if you're in a lifetime
relationship as i am
with heather it's a lifetime exploration
and
that is mirrored in the idea
of a dance in which you know
you you are coordinating with another
person
right to move in such a way that it
achieves what you both want to achieve
so it is at least analogous in that
regard
and then there are other regards and
this is where this gets complex i think
um well actually i have a question for
you that i don't know the answer to from
what i've read
of your work can a father and daughter
dance the tango
uh yes so in argentina um you often see
family members dancing tango
and quite often um
fathers will take their daughters to the
mulanga when they're still too young to
really go out
late at night because the longer it
takes place very late
too young to really go out late at night
on their own so that they can
dance so you do see family members
dancing
mothers and sons fathers and daughters
and there are a couple of professional
couples also
who are parent-child couples and and um
or brother-sister couples
so that that does happen because of
course
there are um embracing somebody tangibly
needn't necessarily be a sexual thing
right um there are so many ways to
um embrace someone and to feel emotion
to feel tenderness and affection towards
someone and many of those are not sexual
um and some of those are actually
not even really loving in that intense
way but more playful
it's more kind of camaraderie we two
people are going to go and explore this
terrain together like um
i think i compare it to two climbers
sharing a rope
sometimes it has that feeling
but it's also um
i think there are a few um
let me outline a few differences and
then i actually have a little
um passage here which is not in the
in the part of the book that you read
which if you like i'll i'll read because
summarize some of my thoughts probably
more eloquently than i can do right now
extempore
but there are a couple of obvious
differences and one is
there's no orgasm and um well
hopefully not that could get very messy
but that i think is important it's not
it doesn't there's no
feeling of teleology you're not kind of
working towards something you're just on
a kind of plan
pleasure plateau ideally on a kind of
floating um and of course that can
happen in sex too but insects there
there is an orgasm and there is a kind
of well well
hold on hold on a second so first of all
we have to
clean up the terminology here a little
bit because you've got
sex in the narrow sense and you also
have
sexual interaction whose ultimate
evolutionary purpose is
reproduction but that's really the least
interesting aspect of how it
functions and so the point is what
you're describing that plateau
may not be like the act of sex
but it might be an awful lot like the
um accompanying relationship
right the ecstatic feeling at the
beginning of a romantic relationship
yes right would be more like that right
it's not goal-oriented it is
uh it is a a realm that one visits
yes um although i think even that
feeling at the beginning of a romantic
relationship can feel very goal oriented
for example you have a crush on the
person
you're beginning to get a few signals
back from them of interest
and it's starting to feel really lovely
and your aim is to take it further you
know you want to
kiss them you want to sleep with them
you want to hear them say
that they love you etc there's kind of
stages along a
um a journey and tango doesn't really
have
that kind of feeling that sort of
directional feeling
um i think that's one thing um
at a at this kind of purely physical
level it's also
i think it's fairly rare for people to
feel genitally aroused dancing tango
because it's hard to be aroused when you
have to
when you are concentrating intently on
something
else so you're focusing on
the dance part of it particularly the
leader also
things like the navigation in the room
um
all of that mitigates against that the
actual physical arousal like people
also don't usually get an erection when
playing with violin and things like that
i'm sure it does happen but it's a you
know different part of your brain is
engaged
um and i the other thing is that
that um
there is a very strong
focus on um
the music so
in sex your focus is your own feelings
in the other person's feelings and those
are in good sexes become almost
indistinguishable it's very sex
dissolves the boundaries between
giving and receiving but in tango you
have this third element which is you
want to
express how you are hearing the music
and you are expressing that to your
partner
also to yourself
also in a sense to other people who are
watching or potentially watching
because unlike the despite what it says
on all of those tea towels and bath mats
and things
actually you should dance as if everyone
is watching
not in a self-conscious way but because
it's just pleasurable to share
um and it makes you dance better it
makes your gestures
bigger and and your partner notices that
too and you feel it too
um so there are all those things and
i think that it's perhaps more akin to
acting
to playing out a love scene in a as two
actors
um and so it's more like a kind of
it reminds you of the sexual normatic
rather than
being the sexual and romantic and i'm
gonna read this
short passage because maybe this will
help please do um
so this is from a piece i wrote called
um
dancing with my girlfriend's boyfriend
and i'm just going to read the
very last part of it um
um
the tango embrace is a very unusual
thing
it mimics the appearance of real life
affection
perhaps if you are a very jealous person
you shouldn't watch
too closely just as you might not want
to watch your active boyfriend rehearse
a love scene
you hold another person close to you for
a length of time which would have
all kinds of implications outside a
dance context
if you gave someone four long
consecutive hugs of three and a half
minutes each
without moving and they happily let you
well things would probably get pretty
steamy quite speedily
unless you have exceptionally snuggly
ball friends
but as always with touch context and
intention are everything
we don't embrace because we are longing
to touch each other
we don't dance because we want to
snuggle it feels snuggly at times
it feels sensual but that's the nature
of the dance
it's not personal our intention
our wish is to dance or at least
the dance provides us with plausible
deniability
the focus is not on us we're not a
couple
and we certainly wouldn't hug each other
for three minutes at a time in any other
situation
so i'm talking about my dance partner in
buenos aires hence the title dancing
with my girlfriend's boyfriend
um tango is a liminal space
between sex and art but almost always
situated
deep within art's side of the boundary
its relationship to the central often
feels less like
raw attraction and more like an illusion
to remind to romance
you feel like a student actress reciting
juliet's lines to whomever the director
happens to have cast
than like a happy girlfriend walking
hand in hand with your lover
the sensuality the intimacy isn't
fake but it isn't real either
which is why i can dance in close
embrace with other women with great
enjoyment but cannot have sex with them
which is why a friend of mine
guiltlessly dances with his sister
which is why most people are monogamous
in their love lives but dance with a
wide variety of people at the malonga
we need the bumper sticker that says
tango dancers do it all night long
changing partners every 15 minutes
sublimated into art we can take
something which is usually
exclusive and without getting rid of all
its eroticism
transform it into something that can be
widely shared
it's a magical mutation a mid-winter
night's dream
a topsy-turvy approach a land of
lavender's blue
lavender's green if you are king then i
will be queen
i'm not threatened by this when i'm in a
couple and i'm not guilty about it when
i'm not
it's fundamentally both innocent and
deeply
life enriching
all right beautiful and it leads right
where i'm hoping we'll go
so they're there yeah
let's do that the question
so you write as if the purpose
is contained in the dancing
and it may be i mean at least partly it
is
but i'm betting that partly it's not
yes no you're correct i should just
emphasize that
this particular piece is about um
my long-term dance professional john's
partner
um aaron sv weiner in case anyone is
he's listening um and um
who we were both in relationships with
other people
um but he was my dance partner so
um hence hence there is
um that hence i'm framing it in that way
but there's definitely the possibility
that
you are dancing with a person in order
to just hold them
and the dance is the opportunity for
that
well the so i want to point to various
different things that might be relevant
to this space
one you describe the situation of young
people
being brought into the realm of tango
by their family
giving them lots of opportunity
to see interactions
that are you know i think your
description is
marvelous right the idea of reciting
somebody's romantic lines to whoever the
director has cast in the opposing role
is both informative about what romance
might look like if the lines are well
scripted
right and not personal because it's
somebody who's been chosen by some
process that wasn't the normal one
and so i guess
there's a lot going on here let me just
explore for a second
we know from lots of ethnological study
that the way uh children typically learn
about
sex uh in let's say hunter-gatherer
cultures
is by virtue of observing it because
everybody's in very close quarters and
so
children pretending to be asleep for
example observing their parents
they actually learn something about what
sex really looks like right
now in the west we don't have that
we obscure normal sex and
we provide high levels of access
to scripted sex whose purpose is to
get people to spend money basically porn
right
supplants this sort of normal version
and replaces it with a very unrealistic
and i would argue
frequently toxic view of sexual
interaction which then misinforms people
about
what the objective is i would argue that
something like
partner dancing and your point about
dances if everybody is watching
dance is inherently public you can do it
privately
but most dancing takes place publicly
that's part of the point of it
is that it actually does inform people
especially young people who don't know
about what interactions between the
sexes
might look like when they are harmonious
and good
and that the absence of that tradition
might therefore be very
dangerous and i would also point out
i was thinking this as i was reading
a passage from your book and then
thinking it again as you were reading
the passage from the essay that you just
read that is not
in some ways a tradition in which you
can dance with
other people's partners without
threatening your own partner
in some sense the civilized alternative
to something like polyamory where people
are
constantly fending off demons of
jealousy
and betrayal and which obviously
threatens the well-being of children
because multiple partners result in
a lack of the structures that would
cause
people to invest properly in parenting
etc
well i'm okay with polyamory um i mean i
think it doesn't work for most people
but i think for some people it can work
but um and i'm also okay with
porn provided people are viewing it as
fiction so the problem is when people
think that it is
um realistic because it's extremely
unrealistic
um especially you know a friend of mine
told me that even when he
was first watching porn at age 14
knowing something about the female
anatomy he thought this
um you know this woman is moaning and
groaning and she can't possibly be
feeling anything
at this moment um because of you know
what's happening
um so
i i would less focus on that and more
say that
um there is a
kind of um
it's always dangerous when
we demonize people's natural feelings
and that
one of the things that i think can be
dangerous in a kind of intel
movement and the no fap movement
and those kinds of things is that um
if you are it's a very short step from
demonizing your
sexual erotic feelings to demonizing the
people who are arousing those feelings
even even if they're not even
deliberately or consciously arousing
those feelings
and it's inherently unhealthy to
get into a state of trying to
blame people or blame ourselves for for
feelings which are
um which cannot be helped there's no
good outcome to
guilt over things that you cannot you
cannot help feeling
um and so i think that the
tango the idea for example that you will
be in a relationship and you will not
find
anybody else attractive
or arousing or you will never have any
fantasy about anyone else is
an inherently kind of unstable way to
think about things
and it also
um i also really think that we need to
we should focus on people's actions and
we should not
try to second-guess their
thoughts and feelings and we should
certainly not demonize their thoughts
and feelings
so i'm i'm not sure where demonization
is coming up here do you hear me
demonizing someone no no no
i don't i just notice it happening a lot
and i i think i guess that tango does
the opposite of that so it
celebrates um the kind
it celebrates attraction um it
celebrates sensuality
and it celebrates the kind of just
enjoyment of being in somebody else's
arms
um and it does so in this
contained in this kind of relatively
safe
contained um and um
and also very beautiful way
and i think it's just a more a healthier
attitude
towards sexuality than than is
normal in western society or in um
or in many societies so
i'm gonna i'm gonna push back a little
bit and i want to make sure
uh that we at least know if we're
disagreeing why we're disagreeing
so i am resolutely
anti-porn i am not
anti-erotic in any way but my sense is
the distinguishing factor between
erotica and porn is the motivation to
produce it
if the motivation is economic i'm
against it
sex is too important and the
competition between the producers of
porn to get your attention
inevitably pushes in the direction of
extreme
sex which i think is in general
not collaborative so i'm hearing
ever more stories from young female
friends of mine
about the fact that the dating landscape
involves men who routinely want to choke
them
or hurt them during sex and
this is a fringe
activity it has become mainstream for
obvious reasons
right in an effort to compete porn
producers
have moved into the taboo because it's
the only thing
in which they can push a boundary
and i must say i as the parent of
children who will soon enter the dating
landscape i'm horrified by the idea of
what has been normalized and what they
will therefore have to navigate
um so i'm not in any way embarrassed
about opposing porn but i do think it's
very important
to say that's not uh prudishness it's
not
the it's not an objection to the erotic
it's an objection to the market driven
erotic
yeah i wasn't suggesting so when i was
talking about
um the demonization of normal sexual
feelings i wasn't thinking about
um porn at all um let alone your um
take on porn i was thinking about more
about american society in general for
example
so one thing i noticed when i was
teaching and also writing about tango in
argentina versus when i was doing so in
the us
is that um in
argentina um people
always felt even felt that i kind of
pussy-footed around the
erotic component of tango and that that
should be always
front and center and stressed very
unabashedly
and americans were horrified to even
hear tango and sex mentioned in the same
sentence
it was like but it's it's you know it's
this artistic and noble thing and
therefore there must be no
tincture of kind of eroticism and
sexuality involved in it that will
debase it in some way so that's what i'm
thinking of when i'm talking about
the kind of demonization of people's
natural feelings
versus the celebration of people's
natural feelings in tango
all right um so still i want to get at
this question of whether or not and
again this is not particular to tango
this is really about uh
so just to describe what i have seen
whether it's
uh the norm or not
in latin america people go dancing
on friday and saturday nights
the places that they go dancing tend to
have
a sequence of different genres and
i think they're typically played in the
same order right so there'll be
some reggae there'll be some pop
there'll be some traditional merengue
salsa
and i guess my point is that there are
certain
a it's a public place b let's suppose
that you were
you know a 19 year old
right not partnered and
the person you have a crush on is going
to be at the dance on friday
and last week you didn't get up the
nerve to ask them to dance but this week
you're gonna
and so the point is the regularity of
showing up
in this somewhat formalized space
that is public right it's like meeting
for coffee in a public place
it's inherently safer than having
someone come into your apartment
right there are rules about what happens
on the dance floor and if somebody
violates those rules somebody else is
going to step up they're going to be
thrown out yeah
right so the point is this gives a place
to observe
how others are doing the interaction it
gives
a mechanism to test things out to test
the waters before
you dive in and it is not polluted
by the kind of fiction that you might
find elsewhere
it's that fiction is replaced by the
kind of formality of it
and in any case my question is is this
solving a bunch of problems about how we
navigate
issues of sexuality
that having unsolved them by uninventing
this modality or making it so optional
that
most american kids for example have no
relationship with partner dancing
whatsoever to the extent that they're
involved in dancing it's either
highly choreographed you know tick tock
style
stuff or it's groups of kids
bouncing up and down which is all well
and good it's all lovely yeah
it's all lovely but it doesn't solve
that it doesn't solve the problem of
figuring out
how you're going to mature into this
ultimately romantic and sexual landscape
absolutely i think that there are kind
of two extremes which are very toxic
for society when it comes to male female
interactions
the one extreme is the indian extreme
where
men and women just young men and women
just basically aren't permitted to
interact with each other
and the upshot of that is a lot of
indian men are completely clueless
as to how to interact with women
and of course a few of them are
malevolent but most of them are just
totally awkward and clueless and
are therefore approaching women in a way
which is
very off-putting and
because all of their natural curiosity
and
desire has been squashed down by society
and there's no framework for it
and you know the tango scene where i
taught in india in pune was just one of
the most
was one of the loveliest experiences and
the indians arrive
standing like 10 meters apart from each
other
and then they end with everybody
embracing
everyone embracing each other and with
this very like
healthy and
warm and sort of natural and relaxed
interaction between everyone in the
group it's just beautiful to watch
so on the one hand there is that extreme
the societies that are the most
the most strongly traditional in how
they police relationships between young
men and young women
tend to also be the most dangerous
societies for for women
saudi arabia is much more dangerous than
sweden
and the most misogynistic
and the ones in which there is most kind
of
sexual harassment and sexual assault um
because there there's an all or nothing
here thing here there's no sort of
easy um productive
kind kind of gentle slope into this
um and then on the other hand there is
the kind of
um the hook up culture
the tinder and um
all of all of those kinds of things that
and
there again that there's no intermediate
stage there's just
you you don't know each other at all or
you're just hanging out
quote unquote or you're having sex um
and i think that that
it's it's very unnatural to
um have nothing and then
sex it's much more natural to have this
kind of
this sort of realm of of
transitional realm in a sense which is
one things tango provides
yes i i 100 agree and i also
my sense and this is very hard to convey
to people
i think the rate at which the
expectations are changing
is making it very hard to convey to the
younger generations
what they have given up in exchange for
what they've got and so you know because
of loss aversion
people are very reluctant to give up
things that they have and so the idea of
tinder which might allow you to find a
sex partner quickly
and you know almost algorithmically
might
seem like something well you really
don't want to give that up but the
question is
what's the net effect and my sense
is talking to large numbers of people
that young people are actually more
liberated than ever
sexually and more sexually miserable
than ever
and so were i in that situation
my thought would be well where did the
misery come from
certainly it's if if it is true that
people are becoming more miserable in
this regard
then where are the factors that are
causing that and how do you get rid of
them
and so anyway i would put the you know
the loss of a couple dancing tradition
that predates my generation so we didn't
have that and i didn't benefit from it
but having
sort of tuned into what that tradition
is when i was
in latin america it seems to me like it
does
solve problems that are undescribed and
that this is
that basically we have a chesterton's
fence
issue right so for those who aren't
aware of chesterton's fence
gk chesterton proposed that if you
happened onto a fence
across a road that appeared to serve no
purpose and you wish to remove it
the right thing is not to say well it
seems to serve no purpose therefore it
can be removed
the right thing to do is to figure out
what purpose it was erected for
in order to determine whether it can be
removed and so with something like
dance the answer is i don't think we
ever did the analysis of what jobs
it was doing nor is it easy to do
completely because so much of it
is implicit and not not described
anywhere and so it's a long way of
asking the question again
are we creating misery by getting rid of
structures that might seem
archaic but in fact we're probably
solving problems that we didn't even
know to worry about
i think um there are a couple of aspects
that i'd like to touch on that are
relevant to this
that are tango specific and one is
that outside of in argentina
many men dance tango but outside of
argentina
dancing is a majority female activity
partner dancing and one thing that i
see happening um again and again is
this um empathy gap between men and
women between young men and women
because
young women often have the experience
that they
are constantly hit on they become a kind
of magnet for creeps and harassers
and they feel just overwhelmed by
approaches and offers and things and
young men feel that they can't get a
partner at all
and can't get any attention at all
and you can see that in the statistics
from bumble and tinder
quite clearly and dancing
really equalizes things
because although
although men often choose dance partners
partly for looks
that's almost never the case with women
women could not in kind of 99 percent of
cases
could not give a rats ass what the guy
looks like
they want to know can he dance
and if he can dance they can have a very
pleasurable experience with him
and as you can imagine if you can have a
pleasurable experience of one kind with
a man you're much more likely to be open
to
pleasurable experiences of other kinds
particularly when the this is
physical pleasure and enjoying the proc
the
in in the close proximity of of
another member of the opposite sex or
nowadays it can also be
the same sex your preferred sex
and that i think is a huge
equalizer so i always say i don't
understand why more men don't dance
tango
or don't learn to dance and i know many
men
feel as though they can't dance quote
unquote
but again not having learned to dance is
not the same as not being able to dance
you wouldn't say i can't
i don't know i can't play the piano or
um i can't make an omelet
and mean by that you would never be able
to do the thing
if you set your mind to it and we do
we learn a lot of things that require
significant levels
levels of physical coordination and
sensitivity for example
many maybe most people learn to drive
and you you aren't born knowing how to
drive and it's difficult at first
so i think that it would
it would help a great deal to
just level that playing field a bit and
that would be
beneficial to both sexes if more men
danced
um and the other thing is that
um one of the really nice traditions
specific to tango
is how we ask each other to dance
and actually i'd like to read a little
paragraph describing it if that's okay
so we call this we call this tradition
in tango the
murada kabaseo mirajin is a look and
cabo sayo is like a nod
literally but it is basically
a um a mutual
eye contact
through which you determine whether
you're going to to dance with someone or
not so you don't have to kind of pluck
up courage to ask
and you don't need to have one person
asking and the other person responding
so wait before you read i just want to
point out
that what you have just described is an
analog
for the way one establishes a romantic
relationship
as well right yeah a lot is a lot is
communicated
before anything is communicated
linguistically
and the difference between somebody who
might even formally know that but has no
experience exchanging those kinds of
messages
and somebody who does have experience is
all the difference in the world and so
again it's like we have a culture
in which we have forgotten that you
might need to
learn how to be romantic
yeah and i and i would point out to your
earlier point
regarding knowing how to dance
that there is all the difference in the
world between learning
to dance when you're young and it
doesn't matter it may feel like it
matters
but nobody really remembers how you
danced when you were
10 or 11 or 12 right learning to dance
as an adult
is mortifying because
being observed and being clumsy
especially in that context which is
uh you know is performative and
broadcasts a message
is uh the stakes are very high and so
you know one message that uh
it will reach nobody on this podcast
because i don't think we have any young
viewers
is learn to dance while you're young and
it doesn't matter make those mistakes
when you're young and then you'll you'll
be laughing when you're older and you
have that skill under your belt
well there are ways to kind of get
around it to create
beginner groups of dancers
and one thing that works for example is
all having an evening where you get
together
and you all have drinks together and the
focus is on drinking and eating and you
stand up and dance a tender or two
over the course of the evening it's a
very low pressure way of easing your way
in
and if everybody else is a beginner then
it you feel much less
self-conscious and i think that although
i've
emphasized the steep initial learning
curve in tango it takes
probably a year for you to feel like
you're dancing
um nevertheless you can
most people can quite quickly find
one person who enjoys dancing with them
and that's really all you need to start
with you don't need to be a popular
dancer maybe
you know maybe 19 out of 20 women will
not want to dance with you
but if one woman really enjoys dancing
with you
that is a huge um boost um
and there you are you're already at that
point you're already a dancer when
one other person what enjoys dancing
with you
you have become a dancer okay again
though
again you've pointed to a case you've
just described an analog
for a healthy romantic life right
you don't need everybody to want you you
need one
but if you can get one person to invest
repeatedly with you right and so you get
better and better
that's that's a success so yeah
um anyway my guess is and i do want you
to get to the passage that you were
going to read but my guess is
that if we really analyzed dance from
this perspective what problems are being
solved in this milieu
that uh when they are solved by
a dance tradition show up less often in
a psychologist's office or an emergency
room or who knows what
right that that it would provide the
strongest argument for
partner dancing imaginable that's that's
my guess
yes i'm i'm not sure um because
there is also the fact that dancing um
i mean this is not to detract from what
you're saying but also
the purpose of dancing is joy and that
is also enough
purpose enough in itself this is kind of
additional benefits
i i hate to do it now here's the place
where i'm going to get accused of uh
taking apart the flower and destroying
its beauty but
joy in every context
is a proxy for value
and so the thing is that's a lovely way
of putting it yes i think it's a deep
truth and it's one so i am on a campaign
to kill off the idea of recreation and
it's not because i don't want people to
experience
fun but the problem is if you pursue fun
as if it were an objective in and of
itself
then it removes the organizing principle
of life
whereas if you pursue things that are
fun because they are valuable right
my guess is tango is valuable
in a hundred different ways and that's
why it's fun
right and that's why it feels really
good and you you point to
you know dopamine levels spiking uh
the point is those things are all
messages internal to the body
of a kind of achievement and
so anyway my my hope is not to reduce
the amount of fun
people have but to get people to
experience it as the reward for
achieving something rather than as the
objective
yes well there certainly are two sort of
important things in life and one is the
appreciation i mean
they're more than two but i'm just
schematizing it like this right now
one is the kind of living in the moment
the appreciation of the
moment of being fully present and
um so that is the kind of joy element
but the other element is
meaning and if you are just
um if you are
just kind of chasing the high all of the
time which is
something i've definitely experienced in
in dancing
there's a kind of hollowness to it
because
um once you have
finished dancing and you leave the
pista you are not usually i mean there
are some
there are videos if you are doing a
performance or something
um and i kind of treasure the videos of
my performances because
at last there's something tangible there
but in general we don't we're not
on video in general
once the experience is over it's over
and it can feel quite
empty because it lacks there's a
satisfaction of doing
but there isn't the satisfaction of
having done and the satisfaction of
having done
has to do with a feeling of contribution
to something larger and also of
meaning of meaningfulness um
that doesn't mean to say that the
dancing isn't meaningful
but if you can
place that enjoyment in a larger frame
then you get a more deep you get a much
deeper um
satisfaction because you add the meaning
element to the pure experience oh this
is
this is that's exactly right and
the idea the distinction between
the completely ephemeral
um ecstatic feeling and the durable
the ecstatic feeling that one can
actually return to
can recall that it you know is
constructive in some way
seems to me an important an important
distinction
right it's not like the ephemeral
doesn't feel great
but um it is
contentless yeah yeah it can
leave you with a hollow feeling
um especially i think i mean tango
can even the tango embrace
can give you that sensation it can feel
like a simulacrum of affection
if you are dancing tango and you are
single um
or you have an unrequited unrequited or
as yet unrequited crush on someone
um and you are dancing with that person
it can
it can give you a very
you can have a very painful sensation of
um it's um of
a reminder of what you're missing it's
the aspartame
of the sugar that you are you are
actually longing for
um uh let me read you this little
passage which is about the mirage
or description of the raja cabaceo
you have to be quick with your eyes
there are two methods the scatter shot
approach in which you scan the room
quickly to see whose gaze you can
capture
and the targeted kill in which you stare
intently at one chosen victim
in either case at a crowded el basil
surname for
malonga on a sunday night those first
few
bars of the tango are crucial if you
want to catch a good dancer's eye
only seconds into the first song of the
tender
many of the desirable men are already
nodding at luckier women than you
and striding purposely across the dance
floor to the seats where the women sit
demurely waiting for them
you need to shoot one down before the
whole flock has flown
because before long the floor will be
full of couples
a thicket of bodies blocking your line
of sight
it's d sarly it's one of the tango
orchestras
and you know just whose long smooth
strides would fit this music
perfectly but he is so far away in the
opposite corner of the room
luckily though he is a master of the
long range cabaceo
he turns catches your eye smiles
[ __ ] his head to one side you nod in
response
you are in luck but as he approaches
your table the
doubt begins to form your neighbor's
eyes are glinting
her legs uncrossing her bottom inching
forward on the seat
but no she is mistaken you are the
chosen one
he comes to stand right in front of you
grinning broadly
you clamber clumsily past your neighbors
squash together
thigh to thigh and the two of you
shuffle into position amid the throng of
couples
alberto podesta starts to sing you close
your eyes
and abandon yourself to the dance
so it's a very efficient means of um
um inviting people to dance and and
accepting dances
in a crowded um room
where um in the more traditional
malongas
people are seated at tables a women on
one side and men on the other
and then basically you try to catch the
eye of the person you want to dance with
uh if somebody catches your eye and you
don't want to dance with them you just
look you just continue looking surveying
the room
if you do want to dance with them you
kind of hold eye contact and then a
little mind takes place
and then the men come over and the men
stand up and come over and pick you up
from your
seat if once they're certain that you
have
both agree that you're going to dance
with each other so
that is a marvelous description right i
i totally resonate with it and i'm
imagining though
two versions of what you've just said
said in almost the identical terms right
imagine a mother
explaining to a daughter that
this is how you
win the affections of a man you're
interested in or something like that
and the other the tango context that you
describe it in
one of these is absurd right i mean not
totally absurd but
the idea that you know you're going to
sit your child down and you're going to
say well
here's the thing you know affection is
all very marvelous and here's how you
get some
right you have to well if the person is
someone you're interested in would then
when they
look at your direction you hold their
gaze
right but if you don't if you're not
interested in them then you look away
right it's like describing it is almost
preposterous
yes on the other hand
dance the environment of dance is
somewhat formalized it is
public and therefore safer
the stakes are reduced because
you're not playing with your heart
you're playing with
the next few minutes and you know a lost
opportunity
or perhaps a discovered opportunity but
in any case this is what you want right
it's
it is an environment it is not a zero
stakes environment like a video game
where everything has and i realize that
modern video games aren't exactly zero
stakes anymore
but but nonetheless it is an environment
in which the most important
features of life are played out
in a safer more explicit
form and that allows the learning
process to work
and so i guess what
what i'm really saying is i think
in cultures where this has been lost
what we are seeing
is like romantic illiteracy
the tools that you might use to get good
at this most important game
are gone and nobody has told you here's
the problem there's an instruction
manual
you haven't seen it you don't know the
language it's written in
and until you figure out what these
things are
you're actually going to make yourself
miserable because you're wired to find
the product of that game very important
and if you can't access it's like you're
living in a world in which
you know carpentry is the thing in which
all
value is rendered and you don't know the
first thing about how to handle a saw
hmm yeah yeah i mean
yeah i don't i don't know if you i don't
know if you agree or disagree i don't
want to push you into this perspective
but that is what i in hearing your
description
that's what i'm getting
well you know there are there are
parallels and romance for example no one
has ever asked permission
to kiss me um how do you kiss someone
for the first time well
you both look at each other you move a
little closer you see the other person
also moves a little closer if they do
you lean in more if they lean in more
that then it happens um so you
are doing very similar things to the
things that you
do when you're dancing which is when
you're dancing you
focus quite intently on the micro
movements of the other person's body you
read those movements and you respond
i mean in a once your practice dance you
respond a very unconscious way it feels
like
as they're moving in this way the
easiest way for me to move is x i'm just
going to do it
um and um but it is about
attend attentiveness it forces a
an attentiveness to the other person's
physical signals
right and let's take your example
um there's something
i find it completely jarring to hear
young people talk about
issues of consent because
while issues of consent are vital and
violations of consent
are very serious the idea that consent
is inherently
about saying do you want this yes i want
this
is preposterous in a normal sexual
context
in other words you know there is
built into us the ability to navigate
these
issues these very high-stakes issues in
a way that isn't
a total turn-off and
the so you have in this case
a very clear indication of what is lost
and what is gained
if you substitute if you substitute a
culture in which
um you can navigate issues of consent in
the way
humans have traditionally done so
and what you get for it is the ability
to in
interact sexually with people you
haven't you've just met
right but how do you have to interact in
a fully explicit
mechanistic way because otherwise how
would you know
what the person was thinking right so
anyway i see in this
in your example exactly you know if
dance teaches you to interact with a
partner without having to say
all right i'm going to move to the left
now you know
then the substitution of that is a
culture or the substitution for that is
a culture in which
everything is done by air traffic
control and there's no
flow or natural rhythm or logic to it
i think one of the problems with consent
is the kind of idea of
that it's somehow contractual and that
therefore
if i say okay yes i consent to having
sex
it's it it feels like a really uh
weird and impossible thing to consent to
um phrase in those terms i don't mean
one cannot consent to having sex what i
mean is that
um what i what i consent to
is beginning this experience and seeing
where it takes us
and maybe it takes us in the direction
that i no longer do not want to go
and it's if the person is at all
sensitive it's very easy to signal that
without words but
you can also use words if you need to um
but what you can't do is give them some
kind of blanket guarantee in advance
right yes you uh you're in some sense
the natural
pattern is you're consenting to the next
instant
yes and then seeing what how many
instances can we go in a row where
we're both into going further right so
you know if that's the natural pattern
and the natural way of figuring out is
that your partner is giving off signals
and those signals at the point that they
are no longer into it
are ones you should be reading then the
whole
idea of substituting explicit um
language is preposterous on its face
yeah you can't ask every you can't offer
you can't offer verbal consent every two
seconds i mean that doesn't mean that
consent isn't ongoing as you say if your
partner says stop and you don't stop
at that moment it ceases to be
consensual and becomes rape
um but um nevertheless you don't
um it's impossible to give a kind of
like a cricket commentary or something
sort of every 30 seconds
now i'm okay with this and i'm okay with
that i mean i think there are sexier and
less sexy ways to ask for consent and i
would um there's a very beautiful
scene in the
netflix series salvation which if
anybody enjoys
listening to this enjoy sci-fi highly
recommended
and there is a just extremely erotic
scene there which involves verbal asking
verbally for consent so there are kind
of ways to do it you can
also there can also be a kind of
integrated into dirty talk like i bet
you like this
do you like that are you into this you
know you can you can imagine a way in
which this could be
done but it can't be
[Music]
contractual i mean as a requirement it
doesn't
work yeah and
there obviously is an uh
ancient non-formal
mechanism in play and the question is
if you have sidelined the ancient
mechanism why did you do it
what did you get in exchange and in this
case
um anyway i have concerns
as a parent of kids who are going to
have to navigate this landscape
that what was surrendered was very
valuable and what was gained
is uh meager but
in any case all right so what
more what more should people understand
about this
landscape maybe um you have a sense of
what people don't get and what they
might right
i think that one thing i've noticed
being a tango dancer is
how wedded people are to their
preconceptions about things
so
many people have a very fixed
preconception of tango that is based on
stage tango which is a very small
proportion of tango
and they are imagining women in
skirts slit right up to the clitoris
with like
fishnet tights on and spike heels
and um really stern expressions and this
sort of
faux passion which i really hate this
kind of angry looking
over dramatized kitschy thing
um and they're also
imagining a kind of quick quick slow
slow quick quick music
um and many of them are also imagining
kind of european ballroom tango which
there are many different legitimate
forms of tango
but i'm just going to come out and say
it and i think
i think almost everybody who dances
argentine tango would agree with me
ballroom tango is not tango
it's a totally bastardized form
um so uh just help me understand
is the distinction that um
[Music]
is it ballroom tango is choreographed
um no i i yeah oh yes and no
so ballroom tango um tango is
is generally fully improvised and by
that i don't just mean there's no
choreography i mean there's no basic
step
so for example in in ballroom waltz
the basic step is take a step
diagonally backwards or forwards if
you're the man
to the side and close and then go
diagonally forwards
to the side and close so
and you do various other little figures
so set step patterns and you kind of
glue it together with that basic step
i don't actually know the basic step in
ballroom tango but ballroom tango also
has
a basic step like that um the basic step
in
tango is only walking there isn't a big
a kind of um
there isn't a basic pattern that you
keep going back to and repeating that
glues it all together
um also the music is
much more sophisticated than ballroom
dance music which is all
smoothed out and has the has these kind
of really annoying
to me annoying recurrent rhythms um
whereas tango has a more operatic
sound it's more melodic um
and also in ballroom tango you lean back
at the waist and you wear all these
fancy costumes whereas we dance
normal clothes you have to be able to
move but
in in whatever clothes are comfortable
for moving
and um we lean in towards each other and
have the upper body close together
and it's not um
um it's surprising that even when i
tell people uh no you are
misunderstanding that's not
how it looks when most people dance
tango here's a video
or if i say um that's actually not how
changing music sounds here's some
actual tango music um
they still seem really reluctant to look
at the video or listen to the music and
they kind of prefer
to stay with their stereotype view and
that's really surprising to me and i'm
sure it's not unique to tango
so it's one thing i've learned about
human beings
yeah i think it's a it's a almost
universal reaction
that and you know i if i can
give a defense of it there is
this problem you you have a model of how
things work
and then you discover that some element
of the model
isn't right and if you unhook that
element you don't know what else comes
crashing down and so there's you know
for somebody who is going to be involved
in tango it's very important that they
get past that for somebody
who thinks about tango every you know
eight months yes yes it may be that
holding on to the wrong idea of what
tango is built of
is safer than unhooking it and you know
finding out that something else in the
model
uh i mean it's hard to imagine what what
would be stacked on tango but
um but i know that scientifically
speaking you can learn something
and uh you sort of need to hold on to it
and the fact that it may be imprecise
may not be reason enough to throw it out
um but in any case uh
yes i guess i am now moved to wonder
whether or not i've seen tango as you're
describing it
because i've certainly seen the more
famous uh
ballroom version of it and uh
i mean and maybe that's part of what i
described at the top of the
podcast my reaction at tango wasn't
something i needed to know anything
about because
the likelihood of my being involved in
it was effectively zero that's
predicated on
the uh famous and misleading version
i think so yeah i think if you see
um social tango danced as most people
dance it as opposed to the ballroom
version um it will be
much more compelling will be much more
inviting to you
and maybe we can put a link or two in
the show notes um
sure and is there uh a
search term that somebody who's curious
to see what tango really looks like
a search term that would be likely to
bring up the right version rather than
the uh
the more famous wrong version yes so i
would say
you can look for carlitos and noelia
so if you look for that couple then you
will find proper
tango and
also if you actually search my name in
tango i have um quite a lot of
performances also that are definitely
not boring tango um great all right and
they're on youtube
they're on youtube yes excellence do you
have a channel
i i not really um i have a
particularly particularly kind of
favorite performance which i'll
give you a link to so people can click
on that and we're also dancing to
it's a very soft romantic and smooth
music and it's quite a simple dance
i would say that
don't feel that you cannot dance just
because you have not learned to dance
and it will be a little difficult at
first but it's very much worth
investing the time especially for men
um if you're a single man and you're not
dancing tango what are you doing what
are you doing
yeah get off bumble and start dancing
tango instead or about
you know this is this is wise advice and
i'm thinking about the question you
asked which is why don't men
realize how much men who are frustrated
by their inability to find a partner
why don't they realize that this would
be an excellent mechanism
to uh greatly enhance their their value
in the mating and dating market
and i think part of the answer does have
to do
and i'm not really sure why males are
inherently so much more
mortified to dance publicly than females
it seems inherent and from very early on
that women like to dance and they
get good at it so that they are not
embarrassed by dancing and
it only gets harder for men because the
older you are
as a novice the more mortifying it is
which makes it harder to start
right sort of the opposite of yes um
quitting smoking it's very hard to stop
smoking it's very hard to start dancing
you know at least as a male um
but yes it is uh it's advice it would be
great if uh
young men took and sounds like
again i learned a lot in your your book
about
various issues including the sex ratio
problem
in tango and its uh its effects on the
culture
um it would be better for everybody if
uh well it'd be
better for everybody except the men who
are in high demand
currently that would be great for them
they would have even more choice they
would love it
oh no sorry no you're right i just had a
blonde moment there i guess you're
correct
right all right so um is there any other
topic that you're hoping that we will
get into here i just wanted to say a few
words about ariel
before yes and i was hoping that you
would
marvelous so i am taking over the editor
editorship of ariel magazine i think by
the time this airs i
will have already taken it over from
helen pluck rose
who i think many of your viewers are and
listeners are familiar with
um and because helen has founded a new
organization called counterweight
which is a kind of um advocacy
organization for people who are
in trouble because they refuse to kowtow
to the work
orthodoxy at work um so they're being
forced through
diver mandatory diversity training or
they're being fired or threatened with
firing for frivolous reasons to do with
their
refusal to be politically correct and
so helen no longer has time to run aries
so she is giving it over to me
um and i'm very excited about it i think
ariel is really important
um because
on the one hand we are unafraid
to criticize um woke orthodoxy
and we're unafraid to throw those sacred
cows onto the barbecue and make briskets
but at the same time it's not
it's not we're not hyperbolic we're not
anecdotal um we are not
um inflammatory and
our aim is not to um
not to demonize or necessarily ridicule
people who are
into critical social justice but to get
them on site
issue by issue most importantly with
free speech
so our aim is persuasion not
kind of posturing and
i don't think there are enough magazines
like that in the ecosystem
but ariel's finances are in a terrible
state
because helen absolutely hates to ask
for money
and she is also was running the magazine
pro bono
because she has other source of income
so she was just basically doing it for
free
um i have no qualms about asking for
money and i also not in a position to do
it pro bono
so um in order to
pay me a salary because i will be
running the magazine single-handedly and
it's
more than a full-time job and pay our
writers
and i would you know in the long run i'd
like to pay them more because we're
definitely not paying them
what they deserve for the kind of high
quality content they're producing
and to just keep the magazine basically
our feisty little magazine vibrant and
sustainable and alive and out there
i'm going to have to just turn ariel's
finances around
so i would really urge people to
if they possibly can to support us to
join our patreon
or join our subscribe star or you can
also make a regular paypal donation if
you don't want to use either of those
or if you can't do that encourage other
people to do it
spread the word um and
if you know of any wealthy people who
might be interested in funding us in a
more major way
i am looking for donors and funders um
please send them my way and the first
thing that will happen when i
take over is it's going to be an
inaugural free speech
issue so for a week or 10 days
all the articles are going to be on free
speech from different
points of view so please also please
spread the word far and wide this is a
blood drive we need your transfusions
so if i can just add to that um the
danger the number of magazines that are
capable of doing what aryo
does is so tiny already and if that
number hits
zero the crisis will become suddenly
vastly worse
as hard as that is to imagine and so
um aryo is marvelous it has done an
excellent job
we now know that it is in
uh a financial situation where
money matters at this moment a great
deal to the very survival
and so i hope people will check out arya
if you're not familiar with it
probably if you go there you will
discover that you have read articles
from reo
and enjoyed them and been enlightened by
them um and so anyway yes a very worthy
cause and
i certainly wish you the best of luck in
financially bringing arya into a strong
position
and in managing the magazine
thank you and please also check out we
have a podcast which is
um it's paywalls but it's available
free to podcast patrons and area patrons
called
two for tea and you can find shorter
versions online so you can listen to one
of the shorter versions and see whether
you like the podcast
and that might also be a reason to
subscribe
and heather has been on the podcast and
has also written for ariu more than once
so
this is true
um also we should have you
you have your copy of your book there
yes
okay this is my book that's me
world that's me on the cover um
is you on the cover dancing tango the
real deal
um yes and it's um so it's published by
small
independent press called no longer press
but it's also on amazon
um and there is an e-book of the
oh it's in two parts and there is an
e-book of the first part
um and there is also these two
um so there's a physical picture there's
a kindle version of both parts
of oh there is now yes yes okay there's
a kindle version of both parts
and i also um have some
dance themed fictions which i am making
currently into an audiobook so please
watch the space
marvelous and i would say that the book
is well worth a read
even if you don't intend to dance tango
it is deeply philosophical and i found
it fascinating
uh each section i read was
well worth the investment so anyway i
suggest looking into it i think you'll
be surprised at how
rich your world it is and how wonderful
a job you have done
iona in uh unearthing what is there
thank you thank you so much all right
well thanks for joining me
on dark horse and uh i look forward to
dancing tango with you when you come to
portland yes
that's not a threat it's a promise
all right be well everyone bye-bye
you